من دون شك ايران الملف النووي الايراني
سيكون يعني سياخذ حيز كبير من هذه
الاجتماعات كما كل مره ربما ولكن هذه
المره لانه كانت هناك تقارير وتحدثت عنها
الوكاله عن العثور على اثار يوراني ومخصب
تصل نقاوته الى نسبه 84% هي نسبه قريبه
جدا من 90 بالمئه اللازمه لانتاج سلاح
نووي لذلك يعني هذا الملف من دون شك يعني
سيتم مناقشته في جزئين الجزء الاول
المتعلق بالتزامات ايران ضمن اتفاقيه حظر
انتشار الاسلحه النوويه وهذا كان يعني محل
زياره رفيع الجروسسي امين عمل وكاله الى
طهران قبل يومين هو عاد يوم السبت ليلا
ليعلن بانه تم التوصل لاتفاقات مع ايران
لحل مساله المواقع السريه التي كانت يعني
عالقه بين الوكاله او ما زالت عالقه بين
الوكاله وايران منذ سنوات في الواقع يعني
وايضا قال بانه سيكون هناك خطوات يعني تم
الاتفاق عليها خطوات يعني فعليه على الارض
في الاسابيع المقبله ولكن يعني هناك غموض
حول هذه الخطوات لانه الجانب الايراني
يعني استرا ربما تصريحات متناقده مع كلام
جروس قال بانه يعني عكس ما كان اعلنغروستي
بانه سيتم اعاده تثبيت كاميرات المراقبه
كان هناك تصريحات ايرانيه تقول بانه لن
يتم تثبيت اي كاميرات يعني
سنلتزم فقط بالتزاماتنا ضمن اتفاقيه حظر
تطبيق انتشار الاسلحه النوويه لذلك هناك
بعض اللغات حول ما تم الاتفاق عليه حول ما
اعلنه غروستي وما اعلنه الطرف الايراني